Pictures
What happened to you Ariel
What can I sayTalk to you.
Baby
Answering
MachineYeah.
Yay
Making balloonRemember again bro. Somebody.
Look upVideos. No you're not.
YeahWhat should you be.
Fine don't laugh
All the shack
For the rest of the weekend
Hurry upI want Undead.
We're going to get a bunch of gems if you
got it's in class
I'm dead I do that because the permanent
food
Spotify
And everything
And then for the rest of the fireOn the
phone.
Yeah so like your inventory doesn't go
So if you have multiple studentsThen you can
put it in your inventory too.
Oh wait there's nobody answered
Who do the bullshit they just torch every
roundI'm trying to switch.
Got a bunny inside
The house
Yeah no
I love him
An old flashlights
You sent the first day dead bodyI want that
bear.
I'm thinking about fire
I'll take it and
I'm not complaining okaySo what you're
trying to do.
Somebody got to do it
OkayWe have a pet now.
And I got to transportAnd two bunnies.
Unless it was mad wood
Work
Something
Simple manPlease.
Doctor
Who always wanted to make a really good
fishShirt. They're going to be hard but no
one.
I don't haveI don't have decorated.
So like
You have them on bandage yeah I'll buy a
doctor I didn't get to go inside
Just wait I'm living my best life over here
Real quickStart like that.
Cuz you restart
MeHey drive me yeah. I'm on your private
server. October.
But I can be best defender
We're going to bed
That way you can drop me your radio
And then we can get the looks like the sores
and everything
Let's pray the mothership crownIt looks
through the trees together so come on.
I got the saplingI know I'm going to find.
How much are ugly today
I can't we need a
Blood goldenDragon.
Africa
Street tonight too
Yeah
Atlanta took him over to the stuff for me
Being able to go online and download
AutoZone on Spotify
The jailbreak games
Any record this spring you only had to put
your face I got to meet super if you do want
to to borrow my webcamWhatever.
I'm just saying all that good thing
Because you put a presents out there and
start doing the videos like thatHe said I'm
saying and when I show my face I showed you
how I look look.
I really don't show you better sellers
But it's good for me like you could see me
you know I'm a person
And so that's what I'm saying you put a
person on like that and does vfc have it
Like this stuff you don't you ain't been
doing anything
I would love to see you up to make one
please don't give up on yourself
All right you can play their game but you
can also fix your game
But I would do you don't have to do it like
me just sit like 30 minutes to an hour a day
that you just get on there and work on that
Bad timing period because she got to go to
fucking work around now what do you mean
whyEveryday around this time.
So that ain't even our bathroom around this
time this is her getting ready to work
station around this time
Yeah in that case you should have took your
ass downstairs you should pick your ass
upstairs and got you out toilet paper cuz
somebody been sneaking and using my baby
wipes and I'm going to find out somebody
else going to give you
It ain't no cheap ass baby wipes
But we ain't going to talk about it
They're not petsNina. They are pets what
kind of weird ass.
Or if you get it wet or dirty it ways to
keep me clean I'm a beat your ass
Got to do a circleCan someone get hit now.
I didn'tMe.
I need it in front of thatI mean a giant.
Fuck it in front of that.
And I want to change something I'm going to
have to do a hand by hand
You want to change something if you haven't
answered by peace
No don'tWe're in a couple.
Again
WhoeverCome on. Brother.
I thought the White House
Ronaldo
I need something that I don't have bandage
perfect
ForYou have to wait.
PhoneI'm not going to bed yet yeah.
No I don't like how they just stop
I don't know if you're walking nothing
I like the new inventory
Facebook Chinese
Do you understand
Frozen song
Flashlight on 5 seconds left
HereExactly.
WalmartIt's a pig like that one guys at
Walmart with the babies.
Not me
You can't hear meLet me stop. Before we
start hunting me.
Up
Google
Over okay
Call of Duty gun
All right look nothing it looks like a Call
of Duty ghost
Are we going to prayAll right.
Cuz I got a gun set cuz I'm not going to
jump back
What you up to
Where you at
Fox Now
I'm behind itGive me about the song oh my
God.
You know I was feeling like that like it's
not that I'm tired of doing my own I just
want that feeling of just going and sitting
It's going and sitting in the chair cuz I
ain't did it in so long
You have to revolver?
Just the same old stuff you're working on my
projects
Working with the kids got Charlie Charlie
about to be back in school ChrisCatching up.
Aria passingWe making it. But I found
something.
No they didn't drop them but I'm happy so
much
Yeah but I don't know when she's doing it
she's coming she's I know she's coming so I
don't know what day what time I know it's
supposed to be this weekend so
I don't know
One
Who's your strong app
It must be a lag in the video for you down
Wade Marco's Pizza they still got that
What is
Marco's Pizza Marco's Pizza
I'm not going to lie to you Pizza Hut
Was it sweetPizza.
Cuz I don't like that that's what they're
doing now all the people
Or I don't bite
I found a girlfriend
The fuck it doesn't go know how hot
All right I'm going to go I'm going to come
over here
Again
And
Rock and roll
All right we need to strategize
I don't know
At this pointI don't know I'm feeling like.
To move my Beta this short sale the house.
I don't know where we'd move I just go
really I'd just go wherever I already wanted
to go
They don't really matter to anywhere I go no
more
I'm hoping everything is getting better just
recently got insurance
In my job recently
She committed suicide in my job
YeahJust weird cuz like I checked that lady
in.
And she wasn't a player either she wasn't a
player she was just there she was like
She was like a little sugar baby
I'm like whyThat happened that day I was on
the phone with you. At work.
When I was on the phone with you at work and
I had to go not today but other day
I came in there I seen that lady last night
that I seen that lady that that day before
because they they just come in and like he's
the the big big baller shot callers they
don't come in often but when they come in
they're there for like days
CanI have to poop.
Is this because their government shutdown
Happy birthday
Bro